well on the box today we'll do power in
the sales okay
what does that mean
you're supposed to be in the Navy
I don't sailboats Penny I land on them
shoot on the Teddy Roosevelt is some of
the most incredible and challenging
filming I've ever done
that aircraft carrier was christened in
1986 when Top Gun came out by the
secretary of the Navy
sitting in that theater watching the
original Top Gun and went okay I want to
go fly maybe Jets off Navy carriers and
that's what I'm gonna go do
ready and three two one
we're on there for I think in total
about two weeks we were all bunked up
together getting to be in such Close
Quarters with people I think it brought
everybody really close together it's a
pretty crazy experience on the carrier
that is a warship it's not a cruise we
got to live as Sailors live we ate their
food we slept in the bunks we actually
watched them launch aircraft got to be
right there on the flight line
being on that aircraft carrier when the
f-18s are taking off as an audience you
go I want to be part of that world
things I didn't get to do on one first
one was getting a cat shot on the
carrier I did on this I'm getting
catapulted off of the aircraft carrier
no one's ever done that in the movie
before it's something that only Naval
aviators get to do
Jerry Bruckheimer and I were made
honorary Naval aviators we are part of
the Navy officially there's only 35
people I think that are awarded that
honor
I'm very grateful to the Navy to
represent what it is to be a Naval
aviator
people moving
like a clock
goes down this one goes off next one
moves forward it's like an assembly line
where there's no margin for error
because there isn't
how many people does it take to launch
an F-18 off the carrier
5000 because any one person on that boat
is not doing their job ultimately that
system breaks down it's a ballet of
Machinery to watch it in action you're
just in awe
thank you
we are TR can we do that we are